FIVE FOR A NINE THIRTY
SCHEDULED HEARING I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO GET STARTED WORRY HAVE
THIS IS THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE FOR WEDNESDAY
SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH WE HAVE TWO
BILLS IN FRONT OF US AB TWO
FIFTY THREE WHICH IS WHY BILL
AND THEN AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY.
WHICH IS A COMMITTEE BILL.
WHICH I WILL. PRESENT ADDRESS
WOULD YOU TAKE THE GAVEL FORME
.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB TWO FIVE
THREE STONE. THANK YOU. SO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WE
KNOW THAT THE GOLD STANDARD IN
CALIFORNIA FOR GETTING A RECORD.
IS TO ENSURE THAT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE SOMEBODY IN THE COURT ROOM
WHO IS. TRAINS AND MANAGING THE
FILE AND MANAGING THAT RECORD
TO THE BEST EXTENT POSSIBLE
HOWEVER WE ALSO KNOW THAT IN
THE NUMBER OF CASES WE DON'T
HAVE THAT ABILITY WE'VE LONG
BEEN TRYING TO FIND COURT
REPORTERS IN FAMILY LAW WHERE
IT BECOMES CRITICAL BECAUSE SO
MANY. LITIGANTS ARE IMPROPER WE
ARE TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
COURTS HAVE. HAVE THAT ACCESS
TO JUSTICE COMPONENT THAT A
COURT REPORTER PROVIDES. BUT
WE'RE NOT ALWAYS SUCCESSFUL SO
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
PROVIDES A PILOT PROGRAM FOR
SANTA CLARA COUNTY WHO IS
INTERESTED AND WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE COURT
REPORTERS AND WITH THE COUNTY
TO TAILOR A PILOT PROGRAM SO
THAT WE BETTER UNDERSTAND. HOW
THIS CAN WORK FOR CALIFORNIA
HOW WE CAN MANAGE HAVING
KEEPING THAT STANDARD IS HIGHS
ABSOLUTELY POSSIBLE AND YET
MANAGE THE REALITIES GOING ON
IN COURTS. SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
HAVE A. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE GOOD MORNING MICHELLE
CAST OF THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION. WE HAVE
THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL AS MR
STONE SAID WE'VE BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE COURT TO SEE
IF. WE GIVE. WITHOUT ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CAN WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM
PLEASE STONE. GALLAGHER CHAO
CHIU GONZALEZ. HOLDEN KALRA.
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE
PETRIE-NORRIS REYES HERE. THE
BILL WE HAVE A MOTION. AND THE
SECOND. COMES FROM THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE. ANY OPPOSITION
RATHER. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE COURT
JEFFERSON ON BEHALF OF THE
DISTRICT COUNCIL OR OFFICIAL
POSITION IN SUPPORT OF AMENDED
HOWEVER WE HAVE NOT YET HAD A
CHANCE TO TAKE THE SEPTEMBER
THIRD AMENDMENT TO OUR POLICY
COMMITTEE WHICH MEETS TOMORROW
AFTERNOON SO THAT STILL STAFF
RECOMMENDATION TO MAINTAIN THE
SUPPORT OF AMENDED AND AS NOTED
THE ANALYSIS WERE BEING
CONCERNED ABOUT A ONE COURT.
PILOT WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED THAT
THE PILOT IS LIMITED TO JUST
FOR CASE TYPES THREE OF WHICH
ARE ALREADY PERMITTED TO USE
ELECTRONIC REPORTING AND THEN
THE SIGNIFICANT FOR MY MOTHER
WAS TAKEN ON SEPTEMBER THIRD TO
DELETE THE TO YOUR SUNSET AND
INSTEAD REPLACE IT WITH A
PERMANENT STATUTORY BAN WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT. BRANCH
AND WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR THE
SPONSOR ON EXPANDING THE PILOT.
TO GET INVOLVEMENT FROM MORE
COURTS MEDIUM. IN A SMALL CORD
SMALL OF LARGE COURTS MEDIUM
CHORDS. NORTH SOUTH DIFFERENT
AREAS OF THE STATE. THIS IS
TECHNOLOGY THAT. THE COURTS
HAVE USED IN THE PAST. AND A
LOT OF NUMBER OF COURTS ARE
VERY INTERESTED IN THE
TECHNOLOGY. TO TRY TO FILL GAPS
NGUYEN COURT REPORTERS ARE NOT
AVAILABLE DUE TO REMOTE
DISTANCES. AS WELL AS INCLEMENT
WEATHER AND IN FACT IT WE HAVE
USE THIS TECHNOLOGY. WHIMS
SNOWSTORMS OF PREVENTED THE
COURT REPORTER FROM GETTING
OVER THE HILL TO TAHOE CITY. TO
ALLOW THE PROCEEDING TO GO
FORWARD AND PARTIES DON'T HAVE
TO COME BACK FOR ANOTHER DAY.
IN THIS TECHNOLOGY HAS ALSO
BEEN USED. WHEN NAM CHILD
VICTIMS OF SEX ABUSE. TESTIFIED
TO CLOSE CIRCUIT TV WHEN THE
COURT REPORTER WAS IN THE ROOM
WITH THE CHILD. AND THE JUDGE
IN THE REST OF THE PARTIES WERE
IN THE COURT ROOM. SO JUST
CONCERNED ABOUT A PERMANENT
STATUTORY BAN AND YOU KNOW WHAT
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
WOULD BE. AND WITH THAT WERE.
YOU KNOW HOW TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND- YOU KNOW WE WILL. I
GUESS GO ON THE RECORD ONCE OUR
POLICY COMMITTEES HAD A CHANCE
TO MEET. TOMORROW BUT FOR THE
TIME BEING AT SUPPORT OF
AMENDED. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. WAS
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT. SEEING
NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
YES MISTER WORLD. THANK YOU
VERY CHAIR OF MR STONE I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE PILOT PROGRAM
BUT I DO HAVE A QUESTION AS A
FOLLOW ON TO THE TESTIMONY FROM
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL REGARDING
THE SEPTEMBER THIRD AMENDMENT
THAT ADDS THE STATUTORY
PROHIBITION AGAINST USING
REMARK COURT REPORTING OUTSIDE
OF THE PILOT PROGRAM AND THAT.
THAT ALARMED ME A LITTLE BIT
CAN YOU TELL US WHY THAT WAS
ADDED. IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM HERE. WITH
THERE'S A LOT OF INTEREST IN
DOING REMOTE REPORTING AND
UNFORTUNATELY NOT ALWAYS THE
TECHNOLOGY DOESN'T ALWAYS WORK
OFTENTIMES IT HAS JUST BEEN.
CONFERENCE LINES OVER REGULAR
TOOK TELEPHONY LINES. THAT ARE
SUBJECT TO FAIL AND IF THAT'S
WHAT'S BEING RELIED ON IT'S NOT
GOING TO WORK WE WANT TO BE
VERY CLEAR THAT WE'RE SETTING
UP A PILOT. AND SETTING. POLICY
FOR MOVING FORWARD IF WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE IN THIS
DIRECTION. AND TO HAVE OTHER
COUNTIES OR NOT HAVE CONTROL
OVER HOW THIS HAPPENS AND
ENSURING THE QUALITY. WHICH IS
POTENTIALLY THE PATH WE'VE BEEN
HEADED DOWN IT IS NOT GOING TO
GIVE US THE DATA THAT WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED THIS BUT AS YOU
WELL KNOW. A CONTENTIOUS ISSUE
OVER THE YEARS IN THIS
COMMITTEE HAS SEEN IT AGAIN AND
AGAIN AND AGAIN AND WHAT WE'VE
DONE. IS SPECIFICALLY CRAFTED A
VERY NARROW. PROGRAM HERE WITH
SIGNIFICANT BOUNCE AROUND IT SO
THAT WE CAN CONTROL THAT WE CAN
WORK WITH THE AFFECTED
EMPLOYEES HERE WE CAN WORK WITH
THE COURTS. AND SAID AN
APPROPRIATE STANDARD FOR BEING
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD. SUPPORT
OF THAT EFFORT AND THAT'S WHY I
THINK THE PILOT PROGRAM IS A
WONDERFUL IDEA NOT AN OCTAVE I
SHARE YOUR CONCERNS ABOUT. ALL
THE CONTROVERSY AROUND IT BUT-
I'M I'M TRYING TO GET MY HEAD
AROUND WHY WE WOULD ESTABLISH
THE STATUTORY PROHIBITION
AGAINST IT NOW. YOU KNOW BEFORE
THE PILOT PROGRAM IS RUNNING I
MEAN IT WOULD MAKE SENSE TO ME
THAT WHAT THE PILOT PROGRAM RUN
ITS COURSE. HAVE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT COME OUT
OF THOSE PROGRAMS AND THEN.
ESTABLISH SOME KIND OF
STATUTORY FRAMEWORK FOR WHAT IS
ALLOWED WITH LOCAL BEFORE COURT
REPORTING AND NOT AND WHAT IS
NOT ALLOWED. RATHER THAN YOU
KNOW WHAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW
IS GOING ALL THE WAY TO THE
OTHER SIDE SAYING OUTSIDE OF
THOSE BULLETS PILOT PROGRAMS.
NO ONE COULD DO ANY REMOTE ROCK
COURT REPORTING AT ALL SO I'M
GONNA I'M GONNA THINK ABOUT
THAT BUT WE'RE MAKING IT CLEAR
THAT THIS IS. THAT IF YOU'RE
GOING TO CONTEMPLATE IT YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO KIND OF PLAYED ON
THE TERMS THAT WE'RE CREATING
HERE. THAT'S WHY THE BAND
THAT'S WHY IT'S APPROPRIATE. IF
THIS PILOT PROGRAM SUCCESSFUL
AND WE MOVE FORWARD. THEN
OBVIOUSLY WE WILL BE LIFTING
THE BAN BUT WHAT WE DON'T WANT
OR FOR COURTS TO STEP OUTSIDE
OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO. RUN
THEIR OWN PILOTS WITHOUT THE
CONTROLS WE HAVE BECAUSE WE'RE
JUST GOING TO BE FURTHERING THE
CONTROVERSY EARLY AND NOT
ACTUALLY GETTING AND SO IN
THOSE CASES WHEN WE HAVE COURTS
THAT. DESIRE TO JOIN THE PILOT
PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE NEXT YEAR
IF THEY CAME BACK AND ASKED TO
BE. ALLOWED TO JOIN ARE YOU
GONNA BE OPEN TO ALLOWING THEM
TO DO THAT. NEXT YEAR NOT.
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO GIVE THIS
AND NOT TIME TO WORK TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS OVER TIME
POTENTIALLY AT THAT'S WHAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING THE COURTS
ABOUT WE'VE BEEN TALKING TO THE
COUNTIES ABOUT YEAH. RIGHT WELL
THINK ABOUT THAT THANK YOU
MISTER NOBLE MISTER OBERNOLTE
AND WE DID HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL. THAT
IF THERE WERE COURTS AND
EMPLOYEES ARE MUTUALLY
INTERESTED IN WE ACTUALLY
WOULD. POTENTIALLY HAVE A CHAT
ABOUT A BILL NEXT YEAR TO ADD
ONE OR TWO QUARTS ARE EVEN MORE
I KNOW. A FEW OF THEM HAVE
EXPRESSED INTEREST AYE NO ONE
HAS ACTUALLY REACHED OUT TO THE
EMPLOYEES. AND ARE
CONTEMPLATING THAT MATTEO
SUPERIOR COURT AND THAT'S JUST
A RELATIVELY NEW CONVERSATION.
THE BETTER. ADAM MISTER STONE
STATE IS. THIS IS A REALLY. NEW
TECHNOLOGY THAT ONLY ONE TRIAL
COURT. IN THE. IT'S USING
REMOTE COURT REPORTING AND THAT
IS COCHISE COUNTY COURT IN
ARIZONA. AND USING SECURE LINES
TO DO THAT. AND I'VE DONE A LOT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE LINES ARE
GONNA BE SECURE. THE CAN'T BE
BREACHED THEY DON'T. YOU KNOW.
LIKE THE WIFI DOESN'T GO OUT
BUT WE'VE SEEN IN CALIFORNIA.
WHERE IT HAS BEEN USE ONCE
IT'S- BEEN BASICALLY. A
CONFERENCE CALL. AND THE
REPORTER CAN'T SEE WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THE COURTROOM. WITH THE
CONFERENCE LINE. OR IF YOUR
USING IT JUST A REGULAR VIDEO
CONFERENCING. THE WIFE I CAN GO
OUT. AND EVERYONE IN THE
COURTROOM MAY NOT KNOW. THAT
FOR FIVE TO SEVEN MINUTES.
WHICH IS WHY WITHOUT A-
LIMITED. PILOT TO SEE HOW THIS
REALLY ACTUALLY WORKS. WE GET
IT RIGHT GOING FORWARD WE
THOUGHT THAT WAS VERY IMPORTANT.
OKAY THAT'S HELPFUL THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A THE MOTION
BY MISTER MAIENSCHEIN SECOND BY
MS GONZALEZ WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE MISTER STONE I'D YES JUST
ON THAT DATE WE TYPICALLY DO
ONCE WE SET UP A PILOT IN THE
LEGISLATURE THERE'S ALWAYS
SOMEBODY WANTS A JOB JOINT ON
THE NEXT YEAR AND THE NEXT YEAR
IN THE NEXT YEAR AND I'LL JUST
GO ON THE RECORD THAT WILL NOT
NECESSARILY BE VERY WELL
RECEIVED UNTIL AND UNLESS WE
MAKE WE ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE
DATA SO I DON'T WANT COUNTIES
TO LINE UP AND SAY OH WE WANT
TO SIGN ON NOW. I WILL SEE HOW
THIS GOES I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE IMPLEMENTING IN THE
RIGHT WAY BEFORE WE'RE GOING TO
DO THAT SO DON'T THINK THAT
IT'S GOING TO BE EASY TO JUMP
ON BOARD UNLESS AND UNTIL WE
COLLECT WHAT WE NEED TO DO AND
THAT OTHERWISE WE ARE GOING TO
GET BOGGED DOWN IN AND NOT
MAKING PROGRESS IN WAYS THAT WE
SHOULD THIS IS CAREFULLY DONE
AND- I ASK FOR YOUR I'VE- I'VE.
THANK YOU TAKE A REAL PLEASE.
MOTIONS TO CONCUR STONE BY
STONE AYE GALLAGHER CHOW CHOW I
CHIU GONZALEZ. CONSULT AYE
HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY
AYE KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MENTION AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
I PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS
IRIS HI RES I. THE MOTION
CARRIES WILL LEAVE THE RECORD
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU THANK YOU. SO NOW A. B.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY WHICH IS A
COMMITTEE BILL AND ISSUE CAME
TO LIGHT. JUST LAST SPRING THAT
THAT WE WERE TRYING TO WORK
THROUGH AND THIS HAS. WITH
RESPECT TO THE APARTMENT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
BEING ABLE TO ENFORCE FEDERAL
ANTI DISCRIMINATION LAWS. THEY
HAVE LONG AS THERE'S GENERAL
AUTHORITY THE STATUTES AND THE
D. FBIH HAS HAS LONG GONE TO
FEDERAL COURT TO ENFORCE
FEDERAL RULES HOWEVER. IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN CHIANG VERSUS
WHEN FOODS COMPANY DENIED THAT
SPY SAYING THAT THERE'S NO
SPECIFIC AUTHORITY IN THE
STATUTE LEGISLATURE HAS NOT
GIVEN EXPRESSIVE FORTY FORTY IF
THE AGE TO ENFORCE FEDERAL
RULES IN FEDERAL COURT WHICH
SORT OF GOES AGAINST PRACTICES
THAT HAVE BEEN GOING ALONG. BY
CALIFORNIA AND BY OTHER STATES
SO WE'RE HERE TODAY TO GIVE
THAT EXPRESS THE FORTY THAT'S
ALL THIS BILL DOES THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. SAYING
NONE. PROMOTION SECOND ANY
COMMENTS QUESTIONS. THE DICE
SAYING NONE OF MISTER STONE
SELECT CLOSE. THANK YOU PLEASE
TAKE THE ROLE MOTION TO CONCUR
STONE. BY DAWN AYE GALLAGHER
CHOW CHOW I CHIU GONZALEZ. YEAH
HI GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY AYE KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I
PETRIE-NORRIS NORTH AYE REYES
AYE REYES AYE THE MOTION
CARRIES WE WILL LEAVE THE
RECORD OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU ALL. THANK YOU ALL WE
JUST HAVE THE TWO ITEMS IF WE
COULD GET THE ABSENT MEMBERS
HERE I KNOW WE HAVE MANY
COMMITTEES GOING ON. AND THEN
WE CAN CLOSE OUT THESE TWO
ITEMS. AND IN THE MEANTIME I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO PUT ON THE
RECORD HOW GREAT FOR WE ARE TO
HAVE. HAD LANDED HERE WITH US.
FOR THIS YEAR AS A- SCIENCE
FELLOW AND LAND AND YOU'VE DONE
AN ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE JOB
PITCHED IN AND SO MANY
DIFFERENT LEVELS. DONE THE
ANALYSIS THAT THE DEPTH OF YOUR
RESEARCH AND ANALYTICAL SKILLS
IS ALWAYS BEEN ASTONISHING I
JUST WANT TO SAY WE HAVE THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. ALRIGHT
MR HOLDEN. SO ITEM NUMBER ONE
AB TWO FIFTY THREE GALLAGHER
CHIU HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE THEN
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB EIGHTEEN
TWENTY GALLAGHER TO HOLDEN. FOR
THE NIGHT THANK
. TWO TWO SO WE
HAVE TWO ITEMS IN FRONT OF US.
AB FIFTY TWO FIFTY THREE.
GALLAGHER CHIU CHOI AND THEN AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY GALLAGHER CHU
CHU AYE THANK YOU. I SEE THIS
THAT'S WHO'S- WHERE'S GALLAGHER.
YEAH
. RIGHT I HAVE WITH ALL OF
THAT WE ARE ADJOURNED